rise and shine here at 6 42 with las
vegas now host mercedes martinez yeah
she's live right now from the mix 941
studio just finished a talk set
a positive story this morning mercedes
good morning to you
good morning you guys it is so doggone
cute you gotta take a look at your
screen
for this one this was earlier this month
during a track meet
at logan high school in northern utah
now
everything was normal and then the
runners
had a little bit of a surprise a
surprise competitor
a pup was with its owner on the
sidelines
when holly the dog decided it wanted to
race too
she ran as fast as her little paws could
carry her
and check this out ended up coming in
first
place the pup was so excited she almost
tripped the runner
now the girl in first place said she
heard
everyone cheering and she thought it was
for her until she realized
there was a dog coming up right next to
her john
alex oh yeah that would be my dog if he
was at a race he would jump down there
and but he would knock someone over
look how fast that dog is can we just
talk about how fast the dog
is usain bolt little holly
yeah look at her legs she's moving and
she gets air
look at that and look at the other
runners you see them they're like wait a
second did i just get
passed by a dog
and then the dog like shows her up he's
like right next to his like so are you
gonna catch me no all right fine just
zip right into the lead and take
place i love that wow oh my gosh that's
so cute
you know they're talking about mercedes
how hard it is maybe to get the olympics
going in tokyo this year
because of the pandemic let's just make
it the dog olympics let's just get the
dogs to run all those events over in
tokyo make it make it easy that way yes
problem solved or better yet move it to
northern utah and just have it there
right logan high school the home of the
2021
george olympics i like it oh that's so
cute all right mercedes thank you so
much you have a great morning
thanks you guys